hello and welcome to episode 17 part 2.
today we're gonna look at another game
where I'm going for terraforming so the
two corporations I have here none of
them actually screams terraforming I
have mining Guild and character so none
of these corporations are actually that
good you could be tempted to say that
all right I have mohol area I have
Subterranean Reservoir maybe I could
couple this with the mining Guild
cooperation and get a little bit of
steel production and stuff
you know it's it's not terrible but it's
not really good either I don't think
I don't think that's really what I want
to do but the reason I go for terractor
is actually not that I have any Earth
tags I don't think I have any Earth
attacks but what I do have for terrax is
a lot of Mega credits to begin the game
with and I'm actually just going to use
this to create effects to actually get a
bunch of heat production
so my plan here is to play mobile area
and asteroid mining in the first
generation and then I gotta play
Solitaire in the second generation
so already I'm keeping a little bit too
many cards you could argue like I think
it makes a lot of sense to keep the
algae since um
Arctic algae
since I'm really going for terraforming
but it's not
it's not really clear because I'm not
really gonna play the Arctic algae until
Generation 3 at the earliest because I
have so many expensive cars I want to
play before this
so it's a little bit greedy maybe to
pick up the Subterranean Reservoir and
Arctic algae but that being said I think
the start other than that I think is
pretty much I make the correct decision
so right here the two preludes I'm
getting is already going to give him
plus one heat production because I got
the bonus and then I'm getting like four
steel and four titaniums I already spent
the four steel to actually play mobile
area
and now I think the correct choice is to
play asteroid mining before I play
Solitaire right
[Music]
um
because now I'm getting two more uh
titanium which I can then use to spin
the letter and the Next Generation look
at this guy by the way what the hell
this green guy so he starts us and he
got already four cities on the map
which is cool that's of course not bad
at all but then he also picked up the
mayor and if you've watched me talk
about terraformas I want to tell you
that it's a giant mistake to to pick up
mayor in the first generation like he
can wait maybe until generation four or
five before he has to pick up this
Milestone even though he fulfilled the
requirement it's way too early to
actually pick up a milestone he should
have spent this eight Mega credits on
engine and then it should have picked up
the media later on
but yeah I'm choosing to pass the
generation with 10 mega credits here
because I really want to spend this
generation here playing solitaire
so this is like a perfect example of
just building your engine with straight
up terraforming and Heat
so I talked a little bit about this and
my strategy as well so I'm getting I'm
not really having a lot of the like
engine all I get is like two titanium
production and I still think it's worth
it to keep to to pick up these two
titanium production just so I have a
little bit of engine
but right here uh I'm kind of like I
really want to taste the letter so I
can't really keep so many cards here so
do I keep bushes do I keep Asteroid
mining Consortium do I keep farming
I think it's a little bit greedy to pick
up one more titanium production
and farming is a little far away
I'm considering farming because uh
um because I know that I'm gonna be
closing the heat so soon but I think
bushes is a little bit more of a safer
choice
also before we get any further I should
uh apologize that for some reason uh the
fastest guy is also green I have no idea
why it's a bug in the game so we have
two green players in this game so uh
um right now is not a problem but once I
start to build stuff on the map it's
gonna be kind of annoying so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna be like putting
putting I don't know my the character
simple on top of whatever I'm building
actually you know what I'm gonna do
something cool though I'm gonna put a
face of Jacob fuxilios on top of every
single thing I built this game so you
can you you know when I'm building and
when green is building
um I almost didn't want to show this
replay just because it's kind of bugged
but it's it seems like it's really
literally only the color that sparked so
if I make it clear which is actually my
tiles and which is actually the tiles of
the thousands player I think it should
be okay but it's a little bit annoying
there's still a lot of bugs going on in
this game unfortunately
so uh but we should get back to the game
so
a lot of interesting choice here strip
mine looks really interesting but uh
I I'm thinking well it's a little bit
too maybe when I'm going for this really
fast game maybe the engine building is
not that important for me and also I
don't have two energy production I think
that's really what it is if I could keep
right now both aluminum
uh both energy production card and the
uh
the strip mine I think that would be
different I think that's something I
would do
but as it is I don't think ah now I'm
actually getting some energy production
but I couldn't know that right but
there's a play where I should have went
for the strip mine it's very hard to say
but right now instead I'm getting
indentured workers and business contacts
I don't think I really want artificial
photos and Status do I I don't think I
have anything else that requires energy
production
so you could make an argument to keep it
just in case I would need the energy
production but Tempo is very important
for me so
I don't really want to keep too many bad
cards in my hand
but I still want to keep even though
that I'm playing a fast game I still
want to keep something like a dentured
workers I just think it's very strong
card
so right now it allows me to play LG for
let's say five cheaper because I paid
three for the car
and I'm a little bit lucky nobody
actually got any water yet so I'm lucky
in the sense that my LG is gonna
it's it's a perfect time to play the LG
but I'm a little bit unlucky because of
course my interest in this game is to
close it as soon as possible
so it's a little bit of a trade-off so
right now I think I can get enough heat
so I can actually play my my plane
production card
which is definitely what I want to do at
this point I want to close the game as
soon as possible it's a little bit
annoying that nobody is actually
terraformed
oxygen and water but
you know it's it is what it is
so right now uh you could make an
argument that I could play the card draw
the the business
whatever it's called where I can get the
two out of four cards I could have ended
this generation playing that but there's
also an argument what if I get a really
expensive card or some other cards that
I rather want to play
so it's always a little bit of a toss-up
do I play the captain now or do I play
it in the Next Generation you know
and I think the reason I didn't do it is
because I have this methane from Titan
which is also quite an expensive card
so definitely I'm looking at the
satellites right here and I think uh I I
believe I did check my tax and I don't
think it's enough
maybe I'm keeping it so nobody else can
get it but I don't know is it is it if I
want to end the game at Generation 7
which is highly unlikely at this point
but at least at generation eight
is it really good to pick up Sidelines I
don't think so but right here look at
this this is just the power of uh of
killed farming right I keep kill farming
with zero water being placed it is
perhaps a little bit greedy but I think
my idea is well there's nobody else
that's gonna have terraform water and
then I'm gonna do it so black polar dust
it's uh
you know it's it's not great it's not
that cost effective but it's
it is a water and I do have kelp farming
so maybe it's worth it
and I don't know livestock Legion none
of this looks very good to me
but um exactly kind of unlucky it's four
bad cards I'm getting with this uh
with this business research or whatever
it's called
so I think the most obvious play here
would just be to play these the stovian
uh that gives me
it's so annoying two green players man
what is this
but I think the most obvious play would
be to just play this uh
missing from time oh there's no not
to wear okay yeah I'm stupid
I can't play it yet because that's not
too oxygen yeah in that case this makes
sense
oh yeah and this Greenery is ugly right
yeah
I think this is uh because the rule
issue has to play a Greenery right next
to your city and right now I don't have
a city yet so that's definitely a thing
I I I'm looking at as soon as possible
to get a city somewhere but um the
screen really looks ugly but I think
it's correct to play it because I'm not
really looking I don't have a CD card in
my hand so it's not like I can get a CD
in the Next Generation
and also my position around the table is
really bad if I keep if I hold on to my
plans because now I'm I'm starting this
generation so that means I'm gonna be
the last player in the Next Generation
so there's a lot of a lot of turns where
people can actually play asteroid and
and actually remove my plan so I think
it's the still the correct call to just
play this really Arctic Greenery next to
an opponent City it's just I don't have
a city myself
so generation 5 definitely what I'm
thinking about here is the bonus the
water to get on the
on the temperature scale
I haven't yeah I'm checking I'm checking
tax right now I think media archives is
the only one that could be okay because
I can play it for five and likely I can
get more than eight Mega credits back so
yeah that's definitely what I'm looking
at
I think it's okay investment loan looks
good ecological soon soon looks good
ecological Zone would be a little bit
better if had more cards how many plan
tags do I give you'll have I have one
and maybe cows yeah I think in this case
investment loan for zero that's probably
the better way to do it
hmm nitrogen drinkers that's right I
think I have enough blendtecs mineral
deposit is also really good but when I
can fulfill this card it's definitely
better
especially considering that there's not
a lot of oxygen and not a lot of
greeneries being placed yet so if I want
to close the game as soon as possible
then definitely I need plant production
so it makes a lot of sense nitrogen
register
so the map is actually filling up a
little bit quicker than I wanted to
which is annoying so I kind of need to
get a city on the map
pretty soon
but the
yeah I think what I'm doing here is I'm
actually just sloping a little bit
because I really want to get this bonus
on the
on the scale so I have enough actually
right I have both the nitrogen-rich
asteroid and I have a 16 heat so I have
enough to get the bonus I just don't
want to get too close to allow someone
else to get the bonus so this is why I'm
slow playing a lot right now
hmm so there's a lot of calculation
actually can I can I play both
Subterranean Reservoir and nitrogen-rich
asteroid I think yes but maybe I can all
right I'm just selling a car it makes
sense
actually I think I've done the math
since I'm selling a card like this
I mean likely this card is not going to
be good but is this only to slow player
did I actually do the math
I think it could be the case that I had
done the math so what do I have right
now I have 31
and I have eight
titanium
and what do I want to play maybe I want
to play both methane from Titan and also
I want to play
nitrogen-rich asteroid not sure
also I'll for sure get one more Greenery
when I okay so now I'm I feel like I've
slow played enough some of the people
have passed so now I'm pretty confident
that I'm gonna get this one
so now I'm finally pulling this trigger
yeah and my opponent is is reacting
immediately by just all right all right
there's nothing I can do about it you
get this
but he was holding on to his seat just
in case I was bad and and
like
set up the the temperature in a way so
he could just claim the bonus with only
the eight heat he had but
I think I I slow played and I looked at
my opponent enough that I was confident
that I was gonna get this
and this bonus here is really important
and also now have enough greeneries to
get one more Greenery down
I have enough plans I should say
and I don't see a reason to hold my
plans so maybe I'm just thinking Hmm how
to actually place the screen right do I
need
hmm
so I think this must be because I want
to play
um
oh I should probably look at landlord
actually landlord looks super good
I don't really understand why I did it
like this
why do I not keep why do I not spend my
oh it's because I don't have a city of
course
it's so it's so confusing right because
all all of the cities are actually
belonging to Green the other green so
I'm like why why am I not spending my
plans but it's because I don't have a
city yet so this play is a bit risky
because now I'm definitely in danger of
getting hit by a meteos or damos down or
something
but it also makes a lot of sense because
I think in this generation what I really
want to do is to create a city so I can
actually put the greeneries around this
city
so it's risky but I think it's a with a
it's a risk I have to take I think
immigration shuttles is the same as the
last game right it's a little bit greedy
but it's also very tempting because
there's a lot of cities on the map
but this is uh I don't know this
generation I want to play a city I want
to play kill farming I want to play
methane from Titan sooner or later
I don't know immigration I think it's
too expensive right yeah I'm not taking
it
I think my plan is already
straightforward I need to water I need
my Kilt farming I need to build a city
especially so I can actually get rid of
all of these plants in my hand
so unfortunately I haven't picked up a
card that gives me a city like ever at
all in this game which is unlucky
so I think I have to like spin the
standard project but before I do that of
course I want to
[Music]
make sure that the
I get the last available TR on the on
the temperature scale
that makes sense
I actually
I think I forgot to mention that I
actually I balanced my hair production
very nicely this game
I think I did it with this card
I'm finally getting Siri
so do I want a little bit b2c to get VP
and do a want to get it next to the
water
I think this is okay so this is the only
city I have it's very confusing but it's
actually like this
no but what I was saying is my my heat
production is actually very beautiful
this game if you noticed I
I think a few Generations back I played
this um
the small heat production card
because then I balanced it in a way so I
would always hit the 8 or 16 Mark so
right now I'm at zero energy production
Zero Energy Zero Heat
and now I can play insulation to just
convert everything to Mega trade
production it's very pretty it's a I did
a good job balancing the the heat
production this game
mm-hmm
and I remember I did it intentionally I
just been
talking about
a bunch of other stuff so I forgot to
mention it but I remember it was one of
the reasons I kept this uh heat
production card a few Generations back
normally you could say that this card
gets better media archives the more we
wait but I don't have any more
events myself and also the temperatures
maxed so there's not that many events
and also I I guess I just needed the
the mega credits right now in order to
play this card
so yeah methane from Titan
didn't I play this
yeah I forget it I played methane from
Thailand then I played insulation
afterwards
and now I'm finally getting a city
it's a little bit late but I think not
not the city is still all right in this
game
mm-hmm
it's still good for sure
and we could get a little bit of energy
production I don't think I'm actually
gonna keep this I don't think
greenhouses looks very good it's
actually funny so I can get one make a
credit production per City I can get one
plant per City
but uh taken into account that the
landlord has been started and the banker
has not been started and also taken into
account and this is probably the second
to last generation yeah definitely
taking greenhouses
yep this looks good I think geothermal
power that's only because I pick up
noxicity right so
so what about this uh
Kilt farming the bonus by the way I
should mention is not really important
right now
yeah getting one more City makes sense
so putting it here and then I get
knocked the city in my hand
that makes a lot of sense because now I
can play place a Greenery in between my
cities and it's gonna be kind of okay
hmm
but the landlord has been started
scientists has been started I think I
could probably get a second plate in in
I don't know can I even do anything in
landlord maybe I can with this
with this card I just picked up the
thing is I have a lot of playing
production and also I just picked up
this greenhouses
and now I'm like all right maybe the
game is going to close at seven that
would be fine for me that would be
perfect for me
so yeah I'm looking at cities so I have
maybe I'm just looking at how many
points I think my opponents has would it
be good for me to close at seven I think
I think yes generally because I'm the
terraformer
but I could be doing some math here
but definitely killed farming man
it's a good car
so I'm also thinking about can I
actually close the game at seven and I
don't think I can do it by myself
because there's both three greeneries
and three water so it's probably it's
very unlikely
so I think I just have to close it
next generation was there
so do I wanna Play noctic City and gear
thermal power can I even
it's like I think I could but it's not
maybe I pick up I don't know I'm like
floating three gold by not playing it
now but maybe
I think they're more
maybe I'll pick pick up a better play
could I even have played both am I
stupid no I don't think they're even
good right
because I also needed the energy
production to play it yeah
then what am I talking about I'm not
getting energy production and nothing
else
um I I only want to play the energy
production when I play natural City so
yeah
that's definitely what it is
I think this game is pretty interesting
as well just because it's like a
clear-cut example of how to build your
engine with only terraform railing and
tia yeah this is really starting tonight
I noticed it right away but like now I'm
I'm like is this really true is this
also the case
with everyone else I suggest my computer
where everything looks green
but yeah
it's a weird book I've never had that
book before to be honest
commercial District looks cool
towing a comment is actually
like if I want to close the game you
know closing like
it gives me like two points right away
it's actually very tempting
but I don't think I'm gonna do it I
think the game is gonna close either way
I think commercial district is also a
little bit too good and also
um thinking that maybe I have enough
greeneries I am actually keeping it
I'm not sure I'm not sure if that's
correct
I mean it's a little bit of a trade-off
right do I want to make absolutely 100
sure that the game is going to close in
this direction
to this generation
then it makes a lot of sense to keep the
the comment but
I think this is slightly better
commercial district is a
it's very tasty at this point
but it's a hard call to be honest
and I'm only keeping commercial District
I don't think I need any of the other
stuff
exactly because what I was saying before
look at my plans I have 18 plans so I
think that's that's the reason why I
shouldn't keep this other comment
because I could just start this
generation making two Greenways so yeah
makes sense
yeah I'm definitely making one more
Greenery I just don't know where to put
it
yeah so it's I have to keep track
I have to keep track which of the green
city is actually my city
which is annoying
but yeah I'm getting the last few
available Tia from the oxygen scale it's
good
so now I'm thinking about I'm probably
getting second place in the end lodges
maybe even first place am I
because I still haven't played the uh
all right and now people are getting
water
so now
I actually should do the math here so I
actually end up having like plenty
so there's a very interesting decision
here a very important decision do I make
a is one more City or do I just make a
ward of 18.
and I think if I recall I was a little
bit lazy I didn't I didn't mess it out
all the way so I think I'm
I'm actually regretting not getting a
stand-up water
because someone else is probably gonna
get it and now I'm like oh now I'm
I'm actually I'm at an awkward place
where I don't have enough
[Music]
okay
Mega credit is to make a Greenery but I
did have enough Mega credits to make it
water so
but it might not be yet it might be soon
but definitely something to
to think about here
but not the city and then greenhouses
and then what I have left
so I'm definitely considering getting
another city but I don't I don't want to
do it yet right because I still wanna I
wanna make absolutely sure that the game
closes
so I think I'm also a little bit too
locked into this mindset oh man I hope
my opponents are actually making this
water because then I know the game's
gonna close
so that is correct of course but also I
I should have also kept in mind well
maybe it's better for me that I make
this water because
otherwise it's gonna be a little bit
awkward for me
so I actually spent the last Mega
credits I've left
but yeah
mm-hmm
also
the the plans is something I'm also
thinking about it's actually very
complicated yeah I'm looking for looking
at my mouse I'm actually I'm planning
out how to to place my green race as
well
so I'm getting one water yeah I think
that's a safe choice
and then I'm getting on this deal of
course yeah that makes sense because I
want to play NAFTA City
so the problem now is that with this two
Steel
I have
and then I want to place my noctic city
and stuff and
and the greenhouses how much is that
and then my problem is I don't have
enough to actually get one more Greenery
so
yeah so I'm doing it like this
but now look at my I'm actually kneading
yeah
so I think I would have enough to build
the last water and then also play my
my greenhouses so yeah
I was just about to make the last water
and now I'm kicking myself that I didn't
do it before because I didn't do the
math properly
so
it's a little bit annoying
so once again if I start this last award
which I'm not gonna not gonna win anyway
I can't play greenhouses so
but there's a little bit I can do
something
because when I yeah exactly I can go for
this card so this is not actually my
city this is next to my opponent City
but the thing is with the few cities I
have
um I'm not gonna I'm gonna have a few
bad greeneries it has no way around it
so I might as well just get this card
and hope it can give me like one
terraform meaning
so uh
that's the correct play to do right now
but I only came in this position yeah
see now I'm getting I'm actually lucky
I'm getting a card that I can exactly
play and that's worth one Victory point
that's what I want but um I didn't have
to get in this position I could have
just make the water but I didn't I was
just a little bit lazy doing the math
but if you if you see I could have made
one mortar and that would give me two
Mega credits and a bonus
in uh what adjacency bonus and then I
would have exactly enough to play
greenhouses anyway so it's a little bit
of mistake here
and also it's a little bit hard to see
because everything is green
but I think this could also be the game
where my last city was a little bit
questionable
I think an idea could have been to place
my city before next to Nature City and
then play NAFTA City afterwards
but I
it's a little hard to see
which which is my city and all this
green mess man
but yeah this is lucky so when
everything is said and done I'm not
getting the last tier from the water but
I'm getting one Victory point from this
car so it's exactly the same but it's
only it's only because I was lucky and
pick I might as well just picked up at
that card right so
but yeah I'm I'm sorry everything is
green it's uh but I thought the game was
very interesting nevertheless so I still
chose to include this one
it's such a very good game to show that
you know you could you don't have to
build your engine with mega credits and
stuff like this you can also build your
engine with heat production and
terraform running so this is like a
perfect example of how to do that
and as you noticed even though I am
going for this I'm still picking up the
the little bit of engine I got in the
early game all I got was like two
titanium production
but if I had like a little bit of Mega
credit production in the first
generation I probably still would have
played that right
so um
but mainly building your engine only
from heat and and terraform rating
that's that's reasonable you can do this
it makes a lot of sense especially if
your plan is to just close the game as
soon as possible
I would have liked to close it at seven
but you can't always get what you want
so closing at a date is also completely
fine for me
and it actually ends up taking into
account that there's only eight
Generations
88 points in eight Generations is
actually pretty good it's a good score
actually
um so yeah uh thanks for watching and
yeah see you for the next one